Отруєння подвійного агента Скрипаля -
чи призведе це до рішучої реакції Заходу,
наприклад, запровадження нових санкцій
проти Кремля? У НАТО вже оприлюднили заяву,
яку підписали всі члени Альянсу, про те, що - цитата -
цей "напад" однозначно є "порушенням
міжнародних правил і угод".
Доправлення бойової нервово-паралітичної
речовини під час нападу на суверенного
члена НАТО, я вважаю, у 21 столітті підпадає
під статтю 5 договору НАТО: збройний напад
на члена НАТО. Тому, звісно, тут слід залучити НАТО.
Я не маю сумніву, що посли при НАТО в Брюсселі
розмірковуватимуть, як висловити солідарність
із Великобританією.
Зрештою, йдеться чи не про перший випадок
застосування зброї масового ураження в Європі
проти мирного населення.
Розроблену в Радянському Союзі отрута "новачок" -
а вона вражає нервову систему та призводить
до відмови внутрішніх органів, - не можна прицільно
застосувати лише проти конкретних жертв.
Отруєння отримали не лише Скрипаль,
його донька та один із поліцейських.
Неприпустимо, що хімічна речовина, через яку
троє людей уже лежать у лікарні і ще 30 людей
звернулися по медичну допомогу, цілком могла
вбити сотні людей. І використали цю речовину
біля дитячого майданчика... Якби в той час там
хтось грався, могли б загинути 30 чи 40 дітей.
Це абсолютно неприйнятно.
Саме тому реакція Лондона настільки різка.
Правляча партія Великобританії - консерватори -
закликають спинити Росію.
Ми знаємо про шпигунство і хакерство росіян
у Німеччині, де Росія нині дуже активна,
ми знаємо про агресію Росії в Україні,
вбивство кількасот людей на рейсі МН17 в небі
над Україною, анексію Криму, напад на Грузію,
замах на життя прем'єра Чорногорії -
можна наводити ще багато прикладів.
Обриси російської агресії вже давно
вимальовуються і ми повинні її зупинити.
США, Франція та Німеччина заявили
про свою солідарність та засудили Росію у зв'язку
з отруєнням. У Парижі Еммануель Макрон
пообіцяв якнайшвидше оголосити
спеціальні заходи у відповідь на "справу Скрипаля".
Проте все буде залежати від дій самої Терези Мей.
Якщо реакція Лондона обмежиться видворенням
23-х російських дипломатів, то й від союзників
Британії не варто очікувати більшої рішучості.
Тим паче на тлі Брексіту, коли Великобританія
готується вийти зі складу ЄС.